fisheries organizations in Europe will
be closely following events in Brussels
during the next agricultural and
Fisheries Council on the sixteenth and
seventeenth of December every year on
the basis of a commission proposal
prepared upon scientific advice member
states have to decide how much fish and
of what kind can be caught the following
year in European waters and Beyond total
allowable catches and fishing quotas for
member states in 2014 will be fixed for
the stocks in the Atlantic the North Sea
the Baltic and the Black Sea as well as
for international fisheries in which EU
vessels participate the main objective
is to avoid overfishing and to achieve
maximum sustainable yields by 2015 the
belief is that managing stocks according
to maximum sustainable yield which is
the largest catch that can be taken from
a fish stock over an indefinite period
without harming it will in the end lead
to larger stocks and higher catch
potential and so far it's proving true
recent news published by the Commission
show an increase in stocks exploited at
maximum sustainable yield levels and a
general decrease in overfishing next to
the intense negotiations on fisheries
ministers will also listen to Commission
proposals to further promote European
agriculture in both the internal and
export markets faced with an
increasingly competitive global market
small farmers have a hard time when it
comes to selling their products abroad
the idea is that by explaining to
consumers the standards and the quality
what European agriculture puts on the
table EU promotional programs can help
European producers better place their
products at home but also abroad finally
the council will officially rubber stamp
the reform of the Common Agricultural
Policy kick-starting a new set of
measures to make it more competitive
sustainable and to breathe new look to
Europe's rural areas